bonjour C'est Marie-Hélène bienvenue
dans notre atelier les petits bricoleurs
la fête de Saint-Valentin arrive et nous
allons réaliser une boîte à explosion
pour cela nous avons l'objet d'une
feuille cartonnée blanche
d'une feuille cartonnée rouge
une feuille A4 blanche une feuille A4
rouge
fil de fer souple
des ciseaux
un cutter
un plioir
un feutre doré
un crayon à papier
de la colle
et aussi
des pinces à linge pour tenir le carton
et une règle
donc on va commencer par la boîte on va
prendre le carton rouge donc on va faire
un carré de 30 sur 30 et ensuite on va
faire trois petits carrés de 10 sur 10
on va mesurer 10
donc après on tire
voilà donc vous avez obtenu trois carrés
de 10 alors on va retirer les carrés de
chaque coin
soit vous enlevez avec le cutter ou soit
vous pouvez couper avec les ciseaux
donc on devrait avoir ça
donc à l'aide d'un plioir on va bien
faire le pli
là
qui a fait les quatre côtés pareil donc
ça donne ça maintenant on a la forme de
la boîte et on va faire le couvercle on
va prendre la feuille cartonnée blanche
la feuille blanche donc c'est le
couvercle c'est 15 et demi sur 15 et
demi
et le bord on va faire un bord de 2,3 cm
donc là on refait pareil on passe le
plioir pour bien délimiter
et ensuite on va couper les petits
carrés
juste là on va couper la moitié d'ici là
et voilà donc là vous aurez trois petits
triangles
que vous allez coller
et ensuite on va mettre une pince une
pince à linge là
pour bien tenir
voilà donc on refait les quatre
côtés pareil
donc on va laisser sécher
5 minutes on va dire maintenant on va
commencer les décorations alors comme
c'est la Saint-Valentin on va faire des
cœurs alors pour fabriquer un cœur on
plie
une feuille de papier en triangle et
ensuite on découpe son cœur
donc après on va reproduire ce cœur sur
sur des feuilles rouges ou blanches
alors donc pour faire des petites fleurs
on va prendre un papier un petit un
petit papier carré là 10 sur 10 je vais
couper comme ça arrondir
ensuite on va couper
à l'intérieur
pour l'escargot on va dire comme ça
ça va donner ça
ensuite on va enrouler
là on commence par le haut
on enroule
couleur
juste là et voilà la petite fleur il
nous faudra des fleurs blanches et des
fleurs rouges
donc maintenant on va monter la fleur on
va faire la fleur avec sa tige donc on
va prendre du fil de fer souple donc on
va couper
un morceau comme ça cette grandeur là
comme tige comme c'est un papier souple
donc on va enfoncer
enfoncer la tige dans le papier et on va
le mettre carrément à l'intérieur
et ensuite on va mettre un petit peu de
colle à la fin de la fleur
et là on fait comme ça et on appuie un
peu dessus quelques minutes et ça va
sécher
maintenant comme on a terminé nos
décorations nous allons
réaliser notre boîte
alors donc on va coller les petits
coeurs sur chaque côté de
on va coller les fleurs à l'intérieur
et on va recoller le cœur par dessus
on pourra mettre une petite rose là sur
ce coeur
on va décorer le couvercle on va prendre
deux petits coeurs qu'on va mettre sur
le couvercle et on va mettre un petit
mot de doux soit je t'aime mon amour mon
chéri
voilà et voilà le couvercle est en
terminé il ne reste plus qu'à refermer
l'autre boîte
et voilà
et notre boîte est en terminée il me
reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter un très
bon Saint-Valentin et à la prochaine
émission et je vous dis à bientôt